Randy's gonna start us off in Charlotte
North Carolina this hour hey Randy
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thank
you for having me sir
sure what's up my question is I'm a
small business owner and I kind of ran
into a problem and I need to know if I
should solve the bankruptcy or use a
company like corporate turnaround to try
to salvage the company okay
what's what's wrong
I've just gotten into a situation where
I'm having to take out MCA which are
just killing my cash flow I'm you know
their daily payments that I'm paying
back and their high interest loans okay
so what happened to your revenue the
revenue was still there I mean the
revenue is still coming in it's just a
matter of you know I think I grew too
fast I was
I went from six employees 18 employees
and I just don't think you know I didn't
have an investor to kind of put any
capital into the business I think that
was just kind of investors fault
integers right now I agree yeah so lay
off half of your employees okay
well suddenly cash flow woman it would
it would help cash flow yes sir yeah
because your number one expense on your
and your P&L is going to be your payroll
right correct and the truth is they're
all gone anyway if you file bankruptcy
and they're all gone anyway if you bring
in a turnaround company and you turn
around companies don't mess with 18
person companies and if they do they're
ripping you off with fees so I know this
is something you got to turn around
you're the man on this you're the secret
sauce you're the one grew it to this
what's your top line top line you mean
as far as what I've made like what your
gross revenues in the business annually
last year was 1.3 million how long have
you had it since 2007 cool how long have
been struggling I'd say the last two to
three years when'd you do the hiring
spree
two years ago okay now there's a
correlation in it yes sir
so you you needed the help because the
business was there and you thought these
bodies were going to roi and they
haven't and I went through the exact
same thing I didn't get as far down in
the hole as you have but we actually
have metrics to watch our hiring around
here and we do not hire faster than we
are aligning on the existing hires we
have to everybody that works there has
to make more than they cost or we don't
get to stay here right right and that's
that's the basic business stuff so you
know that that's and it's a challenge
man it's a challenge because you
everybody you put in place doesn't save
you
revenue and and and all of them don't
make you revenue equal to what they
costs but overall they have to free up
people if their support or if their
support team to do that so yeah you're
you're in a but you're in crisis mode if
you're doing NCA's menu that's payday
lenders I mean you're getting hammered
yes sir yes sir most definitely you're
running desperate too desperate too
desperate too desperate and it's it's
really getting not fun are you married
separated
how old are you 32 37 okay that's about
right all right when I went through
losing everything and I don't think
you're gonna lose everything I think you
caught it in time you're just gonna have
to make some really painful decisions or
they're gonna be made for you
one of the things that happened to me
was it I got a tattoo on my spirit I
don't have a tattoo but I have a tattoo
on my spirit a wood-burning set engraved
on my spirit God first
Sharyn second kids third business fourth
and when you get with your back against
the wall with bankers pointing their gun
at your face you get that out of whack
and that's why I asked about your
marriage because there's a high
correlation between entrepreneurs going
through hell and their marriage going
through hell so if there's anything you
can do to work on your marriage
aggressively while cutting your expenses
aggressively and you really do have to
cut your payroll in half
even if it means you just call some
customers up and go we're not going to
be able to take care of you I thought we
were I wanted to I'm really disappointed
I know you're disappointed I know you're
gonna be angry I just can't do this job
whatever it is you do I mean you notice
I haven't asked what you do but you may
not be able to fulfill some of your
promises as my point but you're not
gonna be able to anyway if you close so
you need like you need to do some heavy
pruning to the tree so the tree lives
and that's what you're looking at here
and and you're by yourself aren't you
there's not anybody you don't have
anybody to talk to it do you I really
not opened up to anyone about it until
you know the last couple days it's
gotten really stressful yeah yeah yeah
well you're you're about 18 months
behind on getting some good advice
because somebody could have led you that
was that's been down the road before I'm
nothing smarter than you I'm just older
and have more scars and so that's why I
recognize some of these things so easily
in this conversation because I did the
same stupid but stuff and so that's how
I can see it so and it's normal what you
did was just a normal thing it wasn't
you didn't anything evil or bad and you
didn't have any malice in your heart you
weren't trying to screw something up you
were just trying to grow a business and
so you're a good guy but you're gonna go
through some more pain at the business
and you're gonna fight like a wild man
to keep your marriage don't let this
business failure if it fails or this
business struggle
if it straight struggle it's going to
struggle on take your marriage because
here's what happens when the money gets
tight she gets scared and when the thing
where you draw your identity is falling
apart you don't feel good about yourself
and when she's scared she makes you not
feel good about yourself and so you
don't want to be around her right I
remember Sharon almost killed each other
and her fear feeding off my
self-consciousness of not providing and
the business not winning and my identity
being in the business too much fed off
of each other and it was a really nasty
crazy cycle so here's what we're gonna
do I'm gonna put you in all-access which
is three thousand dollars a year but I'm
gonna pay for it that's our online
coaching program for business leaders
and I'm gonna get you one of our
business coaches right now and one of
them is gonna hold you by the hand and
walk with you through this you're not
doing anything anybody else hadn't done
before you but you're gonna have to make
some really difficult calls and I think
you can keep this thing I think it can
survive I think you still got some gas
in your tank emotionally and I know the
business does get a million dollars
coming in man we can fix this but you're
gonna have to cut your expenses and
you're have to be embarrassed some
places and it's gonna hurt but you're
gonna survive we'll walk with your
brother
hold on Madison's gonna pick up we'll
get you with our coaching team